bonjour claude ravi de vous retrouver
dans la matinale berthet france on va
parler de la situation au proche orient
avec cette invitation notamment hier de
l'egypte qui invite le hamas et le fatah
au caire en vue d'une réconciliation
est ce que le caire peut aider à cette
réconciliation selon vous oui le
président sissi est certainement le
mieux placé pour tenter cette
réconciliation
mais ça va être extraordinairement
difficile pour ces que présidence ici a
joué un rôle clé dans la négociation de
l'accord de cessez le feu
il ya quelques jours mais évidemment la
situation qui prévaut aujourd'hui entre
le hamas et le parti de monsieur mahmoud
abbas est évidemment une situation
différente de ce qui existait il ya
quelques années
le hamas s'est renforcé au cours des
combats au cours de la guerre avec
israël et monsieur mahmoud abbas malgré
la visite d'entonner clinton il ya il ya
quelques jours est un peu en position de
faiblesse alors pas institutionnellement
puisqu'il est le président le
gouvernement et d'ailleurs si monsieur
sisi elle a très bien noté puisqu'il lui
propose de présider avec lui cette
réunion de la réconciliation
mais sur le fond c'est mahmoud abbas est
celui qui a refusé les élections un peu
au dernier moment en les renvoyant aux
calendes grecques sous le prétexte un
peu un peu futiles que l'élan liberté de
réalisation n'était pas garantie à
jérusalem est
or évidemment le hamas comptait beaucoup
sur ces élections pour mesurer le
nouveau rapport de force
donc c'est là dessus que se déroulera
probablement la négociation car mahmoud
abbas fort probablement finira par
accepter d'aller au caire le hamas
on l'a vu hier aussi a appelé à un
vendredi de la colère dans les
territoires palestiniens
ça fait suite on le rappelle à dix jours
de conflit intense entre entre israël et
le hamas cette journée de la colère
vendredi ne risque-t-elle pas de
relancer les tensions claude si bien sûr
malheureusement le hamas exploite encore
une fois la leaf et politique qui est le
bénéfice politique qu'il retire de la
guerre avec israël de cette guerre
éclair et a bien vu que les mulets que
les quelques qu'aucune les choses
bougeaient à la fois en israël et en
cisjordanie
donc il a déclaré pour après demain
cette journée de la colère en
cisjordanie c'est évidemment une pierre
dans le jardin de monsieur mahmoud abbas
qui avec les israéliens va probablement
essayer de limiter au maximum les
manifestations de cette journée de la
colère qui peut à tout moment bien
entendu dégénérait c'est donc c'est donc
une journée à hauts risques
ce vendredi à surveiller évidemment
queen claude de la question
palestinienne on sait que le
gouvernement est en train à falaise on
est en train d'essayer de trouver une
coalition en ce moment en israël avec la
présence de l'ultra droite est ce que la
question palestinienne ne risque pas
d'être relégué au second plan au second
plan pas pas plus qu'avec le
gouvernement netanyahu certainement
puisque le premier ministre dans cette
coalition serait très probablement
monsieur naftali bennet du parti
nationaliste religieux qui est l'avocat
de la poursuite de l'installation de
colons israéliens sur de nouvelles
terres ce n'est pas très favorable à une
solution de la question palestinienne
néanmoins on voit bien que si vraiment
ce soir se dessiner la fin de la période
netanyahu la fin du régime netanyahu un
vent nouveau souffle au ray et il est
possible que là encore avec
l'intervention des grands médiateur de
la région l'egypte la jordanie mais
aussi en arrière-plan les
brand pays qui ont un intérêt à aller
vers une solution
eh bien peut-être qu'une nouvelle
négociation pourrait s'engager
ça sera là encore extraordinairement
difficile mais je dirais pas plus
qu'avec un gouvernement netanyahu
est-ce que ça négocie toujours
d'ailleurs on attend évidemment
l'annnonce de cette coalition
aujourd'hui ils étaient assez confiants
de pouvoir le faire hier soir c'est le
cas où ça négocie encore monsieur lire
la pizza encore jusqu'à ce soir puisque
c'est le délai constitutionnel qui lui a
été donné pour aller dire au président
reveal
j'ai formé une coalition ce qui voudrait
dire que il a rassemblé un certain
nombre de partis pour former un
gouvernement qui obtiendrait 61 une loi
à la knesset
le régime est parfaitement parlementaire
il faut donc que le futur gouvernement
et une majorité à la knesset
alors c'est évidemment une coalition
fait un peu de bric et de broc puisque
elle comporte à la fois des
nationalistes religieux comme monsieur
naftali bennett qui serait d'ailleurs
premier ministre mais aussi le soutien
d'un parti arabe ce serait la première
fois dans l'histoire d'israël avec le
ram qui peut d'ailleurs envisagé
semble-t-il un soutien sans
participation directe au gouvernement
mais évidemment avec néanmoins
l'obtention d'un certain nombre de
postes de responsabilité c'est à dire là
dessus que tout bloc c'est la
distribution des postes hier apparemment
madame royal est jaked demandait à
absolument avoir une place dans le
conseil de nomination des juges
et c'était précisément la place qui
était promise au parti travailliste
donc à chaque fois sur les postes clés
il y en repart dans la négociation il
semble bien que monsieur avigdor
lieberman est obtenu le ministère des
finances
mais les finances l'agriculture
la justice post ultrasensible évidemment
font toujours l'objet de négociations
jusqu'en fin de cet après midi du 2 mai
blanchemaison pour toutes ces
explications c'est elle évite aux
diplômes de la matinale d'ayrté france